look who's back again this guy and his
wife a couple of people just sitting at
a table talking about also known as a
podcast the a podcast guy today's
episode is sponsored by Mint mobile
Felix gray hems and Robin Hood god bless
them and God bless you yes you watching
right now me no Dan Dan bless you too
Dan
bless everybody I'm blessing the world
thanks dude
dan was watching back no that's how
everyone felt though touching phones
here Dan bless you guys give us a ring
at eight oh eight hot meme one lucky
caller will get a chance to play know
your meme that's right so special to win
a brand-new Samsung Galaxy S nine
compliments of Samsung featuring run for
the cube yes run for the cube the
legendary green loved candy surgeon hit
me with some of those sound effects
would you let's pipe refresh their
memory if we could that's great
excellent next week on Wednesday we've
got the two legends with us Tom Segura
and Christina P they're back on
Wednesday the 7th at 4 p.m. guess what's
also back the suggestions thread on our
subreddit if you have questions for
those two lovely people leave him there
and excited to announce bill works the
incredible YouTube legend he is a
YouTube legend he's doing he's on an
island in a sense he's creating some of
the best original creative content I've
seen on YouTube not much is known about
him actually which is I'm super excited
to meet him have him on the show that's
it a couple of weeks from now I'm very
excited about that thank you guys
Halloween how was your Halloween ela
very boring yeah we didn't
even have one person knocking on door
not one what happened to Halloween when
I was a kid it was like a block party I
was telling Gila I walk I see kids these
days with little pumpkin buckets that's
cute
I used to walk around with a frickin
pillowcase because I was out candy what
is currency at that age are you kidding
me that's like getting once for the
strip joint now I could imagine because
I in Israel we don't do it so I don't
I've never experienced it [ __ ] I love
candy well you had a little taste of it
because um we were walking down the
street there's nobody there
the Sun is like set it's a beautiful
people have decorated you know yeah and
there's one lonesome kid with an N and
yeah I'm like dude we only saw one super
long suburban block just one kid and two
parents and I was like that's just
that's so crappy what's going on that is
bizarre
just one poor kid I was like I'd be
embarrassed about that kid where's
everybody but anyway there was you know
how people when they're not there they
bring they have a little bucket that
says only take one so me Neela were
walking our dog and somebody was kind
enough to put out one of these buckets
and we took one yeah and it was a toy I
tell you if I wasn't a joy what candy
did you get here
I'm coming beerus call me verse I got
the Milk Duds that's that was always my
favorite the Milk Duds a starburst
person oh yeah but as I as I get older
and I eat Milk Duds I realize not good I
like the flavor but it's such a schlep
to put those down as the caramel just
gets everywhere as the key don't give a
[ __ ] that you eat those like aspirin
when I was a kid Reese's Cups that that
was like that's the Bitcoin mmm the one
candy there would always be like you'd
get this huge pillowcase and then over
the course of a month you would have
like whatever eat everything have little
kitty diabetes and then all the shitty
candies would be left that you don't
like yeah so the ones that I that were
always left for me were
nerds hate nerds oh dude hate nerds
they're the sour little oh I like
pebbles hate nerds they're so lame but
that's what I'm saying yeah you would
you would broke you would broker the
shitty candy with other people be like
you want some nerds and they'd be like
you want Milk Duds and I'm like now this
is this is like a little lesson in world
trade you know what I mean it's a
beautiful thing so this suckers like
these little shitty suckers you get in
doctors office like give me a break
you know these there's [ __ ] in
this planet that are giving out like I
remember someone giving up pennies
pennies pennies what and I remember
people I can't got like fruit and I'm
like oh cool for you dude you're doing a
little protest against candy on
Halloween but in life but I love
Halloween
sadly I don't know in LA you just have
to know where to go I don't know I guess
our neighborhood was literally empty
yeah that's not the same thing not even
an exaggeration it was actually empty
but I hope you all had a wonderful
blessed Halloween full of spooks and
streets mm-hmm
I've got some great Halloween footage to
share with you guys at the top of this
beautiful Friday afternoon I just
remembered I did want to give a shredder
update
oh shut her up I see a lot of people
still think that he eats poop oh no no
no I just wanted cuz I see it sometimes
yeah I just wanna say stop doing that
he's a good boy now he's a sweet ain't
no like he's a big boy he doesn't need
to I don't want to misrepresent shredder
no he's not a [ __ ] eater he hasn't eaten
[ __ ] and I know he doesn't do it anymore
one day he was like hey you know what
I'm gonna groaning I'm gonna stop eating
[ __ ] and wasn't that a great day for all
of us because sometimes he'd come and
lick you right in the mouth and you feel
like you yeah dude
cute and also I can taste [ __ ] you just
ate [ __ ] like Korean oh I love you
anyway that's kind of what parenthood is
right probably you just [ __ ] my mouth
and I love you
so I we spoke about these gracious
people that leave the buckets of candy
in the front yard that says only take
one but as you may or may not know as
Halloween is new to you there's always
some piece of crap that dumps the whole
freakin bucket out into their pillowcase
and it just it's not right it's not
right but here now I've got some clips
of my favorite that I found of this year
these are all fresh of parents getting
in on the good spirit of Halloween no
gala take we are about to have a kid so
notice on the good parenting now I want
to show I want to point something out
this sweetheart take it one go on
exactly the kid has a sweet pure heart
he reads the sign and he says I'll only
take one I'm a sweet pure soul but life
this is what happens when life gets to
you you become this lady and here's what
happens not not clean the bucket she's
scooping it like it's her life depends
on it and the poor kid like that's the
example that he has to follow I know it
breaks my heart because he was a sweet
kid it's like it's just candy lady what
we're saying like no let's see I'm
sacred
the kid is saying mommy come on yeah
oh man that breaks my heart it said
mommy come on you can only take one good
what a sweet soul what do you mean
what's the candy
it's just candy it's not insulin you
know what I mean
what are they you know this kid like
this kids not it doesn't have a good
shot
coming up right but he has a pure heart
yeah and I love that for him when your
eight-year-old has a better moral
compass than you also don't people under
like I always see videos of people
stealing packages from front doors like
you know that everybody has like ring
now we're all watch some people gonna
catch up yet yeah we're watching so
there you go
you know stealing it like her life
depends on it
I saw one comment on the video that said
what are the chances the kid sees any of
it that candy yeah I'm wondering too cuz
it is it for her why would you just buy
candy you can get so much candy for like
$1 at Ralph's yeah also sales the next
day are freaking nuts so here's a family
that ransac scible little uh pick me up
on this Friday afternoon ring.com
ball hitter yes sir but it's like yeah
it's not a riot there's not flooding
there's not a zombie apocalypse [ __ ]
that's a come on let's go you don't rob
people on him any other day that's what
you're doing you're robbing you know go
you'll see what happen they left a
little girl and she's they open the door
they left the little girl - yeah I
missed that great parents yeah you know
take note because we have a lot to learn
about parenting
I can't wait to ransacks and and then
finally the theme of Halloween this one
is old
and the theme of you know dressing up in
a costume these guys were promoting a
musical and Ninja Turtles musical and
they started talking about wanting to
bank April and there's like all these
kids there who are like Turtles mega
fans and I was just blown away by this
clip it's a train on April
that's not canon that is not part of the
Ninja Turtles lore hey April you wanna
you wanna interspecies relationship with
all four of us too bad she can't hold
her breath long enough I'm gonna drown
her in jizz
well because the turtles aren't in water
they don't you know they walk around the
earth didn't they mean that they stink
she says they can't hold her breath long
enough I assume he means because turtles
are water creatures
I thought they mean cuz they think why
would that why would she need to be
underwater for because they stink not to
hold her breath uh I don't necessarily
understand the implication but it
doesn't seem right either way I can't
hold her breath long enough
I assume cuz they're drowning her and
come it's a bunch of [ __ ] heavy sack
Turtles here you know what I mean look
at this look at this kids on the left he
is traumatized yeah that is pretty
badass
I love that fire I was good but this
poor kid on the Left man he's no kid
should see hey because you know every
kid has a
have a crush on April because she's kind
of a hot cartoon character and he
probably wants to [ __ ] April and now all
the sudden he's got to imagine his
turtle friends [ __ ] blocking him me -
moaning Donatello
yeah - the kids
cut - the kids dramatize yeah he looks
like an adult just like damn mm-hmm
Donatello did you wanna say something
I'll see you report it's hard for me not
to analyze and a good thing about these
guys is it there have huge turtle [ __ ]
they may be turtles but they're hung
like a horse so there you go happy
Halloween everybody I am feeling better
by the way thank you for asking
still have a kofta it's just brutal but
let's talk about eeeh who's pregnant
mm-hmm how are you feeling I feel okay
no morning sickness no you're gaining
weight mm-hmm wait I'm not fitting in my
pants already and didn't you I have to
say this you got [ __ ] bad eyes I have
to say it good why do you have to say
Katie's got [ __ ] not yes okay that's
not good there all right the same we're
talking about being pregnant you know
I'm just I'm just noticing the changes
that are happening here buddy we got our
first ultrasound we sign the baby your
thickening up is my point like yeah it's
you've get how much weight have you
gained since we found out like five or
six pounds it's pretty amazing
something that no you look did you look
amaze a you look so
beautiful so radiant you look amazing
you are like I'm telling you you're free
even like - I think it's amazing that
you're pregnant
yeah and so we saw we saw the little
pipsqueak because we did an ultrasound
and here I got a video for you it's such
a trap to me yeah that you can see the
heartbeat in this whole [ __ ] guy this
little [ __ ] and the doctor said he looks
like a gummy bear yeah he's a little
gummy bear yeah he I don't know but you
see the heartbeat right here here let me
pull screaming look at that thing man
that's inside and it's like moving yeah
he's swimming around his legs are
wiggling and [ __ ] that's so crazy so
this is the head and the body and the
arms and legs are starting to form and
he's got a little heartbeat I'm go
that little guy's cooking up in your
stomach it's so weird how does it feel
like that there's like a life growing in
you and so weird because I don't feel it
you don't but like you know that it's
there yeah it's crazy it's pretty
magical I guess I don't know it's like
yeah what we're meant to do but it's so
insane it's interesting how we're so
removed from nature in a way yeah that
we find like birth to be so magical but
it is magical yeah it's really something
I just [ __ ] it we just did it you know
what I mean and now there's a little
heartbeat inside you I'm are we've run
the danger of gushing over our kids and
nobody cares I'm ready gushing over this
little because I saw people um asking
for the baby updates right so I guess
let us know because I know I hate
hearing about other people's kids and I
and I was like everybody does and it's
like because you don't you know that's
true I never understood how special it
feels yeah
and so I don't know if we're already
running that danger it's like ultra
sounds like I already loved that little
gummy bear look at him he's a crush his
heartbeat is so strong his heartbeat is
so strong what they say in the DNA test
at super athlete's body it is super
athlete heartbeat I'm telling you he's
gonna be President someday I want to
wish I wouldn't wish being president on
my worst enemy
talk about the worst job of the road I
didn't write there it is man
ela is doing great dude you are doing
great you get a little tired sometimes I
get really tired and I I get pretty
hungry and then I'll eat and then I'm
like dead I'm ready to sleep so I'm kind
of like a baby like I'm eating sleeping
you have a life force cutting your
energy out you have a foreign you're a
host and I do have cravings for people
who were wondering if it's true or not
it's like all of a sudden I really feel
like eating something
mac and cheese this morning or I'll
really not feel like getting something
Mexican food yeah it's so weird he looks
like I don't want Mexican food any more
I'm like Jews really I love it it's like
oh wait this morning she's like Ethan
you need to make Matt contribute I was
like it's like oh I was walking
straighter and all of a sudden I'm like
mac and cheese that's what I mean but
the interesting thing is about the
cravings is that I wonder if there's
really some actual science behind it
well I think there is because there was
one week where all of a sudden every
night I wanted Adam mommy I don't know
where yeah it's a soy bean and it's I
think it's really good for you too so
and now I'm completely over it I don't
touch it
interestingly that was before we knew
you were pregnant but I was yeah I don't
know but like you were craving mac and
cheese and I wonder if you needed like
calcium and the vitamins and all this
dairy and stuff awesome and butter and
cheese fat lots of fat yeah you know
very cool man very exciting stuff you
know
but I have so much appreciation I really
do now that you are raising this child
in your stomach and you're gonna give
birth to this child I'm really afraid of
that all guys have to do is nut there's
nothing easier in the world than nothing
I think I'll be okay until like the
fifth month or something but then things
started to get hard I'm scared that's
Carol over that part I know you're
scared but I'm excited and I because I
know it's gonna be fine and I know
you're gonna be great and I can't wait
to see the transformation and everything
and all the changes and like you growing
it's gonna be so wild but I understand
you're scared it is scary I would be
scared too if it was me yeah but I know
everything's gonna be great and I'm
looking at like maternity clothes and
it's so not my style there's got to be
hit oh no what am I gonna wear I already
don't fit in my clothes
yeah I wonder if there's any Gucci
maternity pants we can get you all swag
down and we started looking at baby
clothes we bought some baby clothes for
our friends and they're like so freakin
cool and obviously way more affordable
but then like adult clothes yeah and I
was like oh I understand why you have
multiple kids it's like I'm not gonna
let this sick clothes go to waste some
have another kid just so I can put them
in this dope ass clothes again you know
yeah yeah but I swear to god I'm just
like I'm gushing over elated
it's just amazing I'm not doing anything
no it's amazing I sheer so cool no it's
amazing seriously something else man so
there you go there's a baby update for
you let us know if it's too much yeah
you know feel over it
stop with the baby talk I get it he's
got a heartbeat all babies have are pee
no but not all babies have a heartbeat
like that one do they all look like a
gummy bear no by the way that heartbeat
is like a sick I could tell he's got
like rhythm and soul to like this guy
the artistic passionate he's empathetic
boy you're a warrior
basically Gandhi mix weather um every
tell the best things you can imagine
boom right there
presented with the opportunity to steal
a bunch of candy he would take one
politely and say to no daddy
let's forget off this no I'm pushing it
to him as the title of the episode
indicates post Malone is under fire by
the media now let me preface this by
saying that post Malone has become so
popular so successful this year has been
incredible I read something that um he
has been the most streamed and the most
popular musician of this entire year he
has the biggest musician in the world
2018 or maybe the United States I don't
know but like combined with his first
album his first album you guys broke
Michael Jackson's Thriller that's a
great record for being on like the top
10 Billboard for the longest consecutive
weeks okay do we have no internet oh I
have internet you know I think so dan I
have internet Oh No thank God we have a
backup system for this yeah anyway so
post Malone has been wildly successful
and I would say he has critics but from
the fans and the people that consume his
music he always beloved
he always had gotten a lot of [ __ ] yeah
he's gotten a lot of [ __ ] but the people
who give him [ __ ] are kind of like these
old guards you know these these you know
yeah but the fans the consumers he's
below yeah because he's such a great
personality he's such a chill dude he
you know he's just a great guy there's
there's no question about that
and she never claimed to want to make
anything more than just some good music
right exactly and this article is
exactly that's the problem apparently
well the problem that this author seems
to heaven this is in Washington Post so
this is a big reputable
this was shared with me by a lot of
people so I think a lot of eyeballs fell
in this article the problem he seems to
have is that he's not woke enough of
some sorts or he sees post Mon success
as symptomatic of all the problems in
the world and he makes all these grand
comparisons to like conservative
movement it's very political yeah he
makes comparisons to him being like
Donald Trump the fact that he's setting
you didn't vote somehow like now we all
need to judge him right that he's
pro-gun or like an epochal Icke a
doomsday or whatever you want to call it
it's all you know used to paint this
picture that he's some sleeper
conservative alt-right troll I think is
kind somewhat they temper yeah this tone
for sure there's not really any proof to
support that so they kind of try to
build this case using things that aren't
really direct right yeah so they don't
really come out and say it
but um and the thing about Austin that I
know is that he's never tried to do or
be anything he's just making music that
he likes Sakhalin but from styles that
he likes and everybody it's like if you
don't like his music if you don't like
it's such I don't know I just that the
thing about this article like it's it's
interesting and it's worthy of analysis
of like who he is and why he's popular
now but it's so mean-spirited it's so
mean
yeah maybe should read something from
the beginning well let me show you first
of all let me pop this open the video is
so obnoxious okay let's start with this
post alone you think you know but you
have no idea also the title is post
Malone is the perfect pop star of this
American moment and that's not a
compliment
sounds like one got him sounds like a
nice I mean why don't you just say what
you want to say that yeah because she
the author he or she Jeff Weiss is
trying to make this point of like he's
perfect because of Donald Trump and
everything and this is wise mm-hmm let's
wash his face thanks for having your
just so likable and I really am
interested in your story you might know
post Malone as the SoundCloud rapper who
went triple platinum for his debut track
white Iverson you might know him as the
genre-bending artist combining country
but did you know that he also raped
babies no okay or you may not know him
at all but you should malone is huge for
context his album Stoney beat out
Michael Jackson's Thriller for most
weeks in top ten on the top R&B surprise
you and in fact this talentless hack
naturally dethrone Michael Jackson you
understand the artist a bit better barn
Austin Richard post he became post
Malone the same way Donald Glover became
childish gambino through a rap name
generator' Malone wasn't always focused
on the music is very eerie in any
meaning it's like crunching the numbers
a little [ __ ] spooky little
something's wrong here he learned how to
play guitar by and playing guitar hero I
started playing the guitar because of
the controller in my
I says let me do the real thing they're
part of a heavy metal band he credits
Bob Dylan as one of his major influences
execs at his record company Republic
Records have described Malone as the
Donald Trump of hip-hop because quote
things that should have killed his
career only made him bigger so here
they're trying to make an unjustified
parallel between him and Trump things
that should have killed him only made
him better I didn't know what they're
talking about this was one dudes quo but
they're just even just by being like
post Malone Donald Trump even though
they say it again in another country so
like they're kind of almost
subconsciously in a way being like he is
Donald Trump and he supports Donald
Trump and he you know they make it like
everything's got to be political they
likes guns yeah it's like if you're a
liberal they say like if you're a
liberal and you believe in resisting
Donald Trump then you should hate post
Malone yeah and it's like no it's got
nothing to do with politics 2016 he said
he'd considered playing president Donald
Trump's inauguration fast
Wow that's pretty much like in 2016 I
don't even know I guess you yeah what
did he know about Trump back down like
no but also if a president asked you to
play the inauguration he was by the way
in 2016 his first album hadn't even come
out it yeah he wasn't a megastar every
word he said wasn't dissected didn't
seem like a play somebody asked him he's
like I'd play there like beats a game
you know it's like goddamn Trump I
didn't vote oh he didn't ball no vote is
a vote for Trump he's not woke enough
how is that damning he's [ __ ] also by
the way this interview took place when
he was like 21 he's 23 now mm-hmm why
political making a political stand hmm I
don't count Malone is a second amento
comment by the way they're just like
watch this and then they go into he
likes goes yeah oh we got mention here
top comment watching this h3 vid right
now that's when people used to like us
those were the days a large collection
of guns a personal front he's friends
with Justin Bieber and is even open for
him on to her ah did somebody say Justin
Bieber do you know he's Canadian did you
know the baby's in the ass I don't know
he does not do that
but what is that what is that like what
what I don't know somehow they're
turning everything into like an having a
negative tone even though they're just
saying like did you know that he's his
accomplishments he opened for Justin
Bieber tour exactly
showing him on Jimmy Fallon like that's
the problem somehow do you know that did
you know that he has tattoos on his face
often associated with criminal gangs it
was it true that like Justin Bieber
talked you into getting a tattoo yeah
well I figured because I we were working
on Stoney and then we had a tattoo
artist come too and then I was just like
you know what Justin Bieber's got some
tats and I love you but I know I'm way
tougher than you why would they show
that he's kidding he's obviously kidding
but like what so what he's even cut it
off before the laughter of the audience
I just don't understand this is the
video this is the kind of preface this
tone this is the tone it's like dude
what so pointless this video is entitled
you think you know but you have no idea
so what did I learn he likes gun he
didn't vote he's friends with Justin
Bieber Wow let's send this guy to prison
okay well now let's get on with this
just weird to see such a like that's a
hate base right as much it's like as
much of a hippies as you can make
without being like so obvious about it
is they constructed in a way that people
who are sympathetic to them don't see
right so we see right through it exactly
but it's very cuz of normal Washington
Post all these he's a liberal a liberal
leaning paper and but he's like a
reputable one
oh yeah Washington Post is like on par
with New York Times I mean it's one of
the most famous newspapers in the world
actually owned by you boy Jeff Bezos
mmm-hmm by Amazon but this is an op-ed
this is not like I don't yeah I just
probably got a lot of traction though
I'm gonna have use or anything but um
you know what I'm gonna read this
article it's time for a break so do not
go away we're gonna dive right into this
and mount a defense of our good friend
sweet angel post Malone on this blessed
Friday see you guys soon big wireless
doesn't want you to know that there's a
way to cut your wireless bill down to
just fifteen dollars a month introducing
the disrupter mint mobile I love these
guys so much and what they're doing okay
these guys are changing the game they
are everything that's wrong with
wireless providers cell phone providers
we are talking about saving thousands of
dollars every year without sacrificing
quality of service mint mobile changes
the freakin game they bent mail your SIM
card you pop it in boom you are good to
go there's a little guy and they're
changing the game Nimbo will takes it so
easy to cut your wireless bill down to
just fifteen dollars a month you use
your own phone with any mint mobile plan
you can keep your old number along with
all your existing context you choose
between 2 5 and 10 gigabyte L 4G LTE
plans no more paying for unlimited data
that you'll never use every plan comes
with unlimited talk and text and if
you're not 100% satisfied mint mobile
has you covered with their 7 day
money-back guarantee do you got nothing
to lose give them a shot ditch your old
wireless bill and start saving today
with me
mobile to get your new wireless plan for
just $15 a month plus free shipping on
your mobile SIM card go to mint mobile
comm slash H Street that is mint
mobile.com slash h3 cut your wireless
bill to $15 a month and get free
shipping on your mint Mobile SIM card at
mint mobile comm slash h3 I'm telling
you this is changing the game it's just
as good they all use the same network
these guys are just hooking it up you
don't have to pay $100 a month anymore
mint mobile comm slash h3 there's a lot
of debate about whether if you're
sitting in front of video games and
computer screens can actually damage
your eyes and I'm sad to say that
research is starting to show that the
blue light coming from screens can kill
you no I'm kidding they do not
necessarily will kill you but it can
give you discomfort dry eyes blurry
vision or headaches the discomfort is
real from sitting in front of screens
and now the technology exists that you
can keep your eyes fresh with a pair of
felix great glasses available with or
without prescriptions let me tell you
about this sweet little babies felix
great some of the likes say they filter
out 90% of high-energy blue light and
eliminate the glare coming off all the
screens so you can be the ultimate gamer
broccoli assassin that I know resides in
each of your souls
usually it seems like a hassle to have
to protect your eyes and that's why most
of us don't do it but feliz de grasses
aren't easy fix get pop them on you can
feel your eyes relax and even as the
action ramps up on screen your phone the
action guess what your eyes are chilling
behind these beautiful blue light
filtering fields great glasses and
here's what's great about Felix grey
glasses they filter blue light without
the yellow lens tint they are hand
crafted from premium Italian acetate
that's right
do you hear how fancy that word is
acetate from italia in fact it's pretty
stylish too yeah Felix red glasses are
available in non prescription
prescription and reader versions you got
it all folks here we go take down your
competition with the help of some Felix
Grey's go to Felix great glasses comm /h
through protect your eyes to date with
free shipping free returns you got
nothing to lose
that's Felix great glasses dot-com /hd
Felix gray glasses comm /h 3
listen some of you are losing your hair
I know it sucks alright
here's the solution for hems calm /h 3
that's it these guys specialize and
keeping your dang hair before it falls
out ok because let's face it you're in
the shower and your and I you know yeah
this hair coming out of your head it's
gotta be it's scared it's free it's
freaky let's face it get on over to 4
hips calm /h 3 and let's do something
about it because with science you don't
have to watch your hair flow down the
drain like a scene from psycho ok let's
let's avoid that here's the deal they've
got well known generic equivalents to
name-brand prescriptions to keep your
hair this is the real deal prescription
solutions that are backed by science
there's no waiting room
no awkward in-person doctor visits
you're gonna save hours by going to 4
hems com it's easy as it can possibly
bleep the answer die I'm speaking from
all over the place answer a few quick
questions doctors will review and
prescribe you products are shipped
directly to your door ok or right now my
listeners get a trial month of hymns for
just 5 dollars today while supplies last
see the website for full details this
will cost hundreds if you went to the
doctor or pharmacy and who's got time
for that anyway when you can just go to
for him calm
/h 3 that's fo r hims calm /h 3 forms a
calms Larry Robin Hood is an incredible
place to learn how to trade and to trade
stocks and even kryptos ETFs options
they've got it all and here's the best
part about Robin Hood which makes him
Robin Hood commission-free
that's why if you're a beginner or even
a pro it's a great place to come trade
and it's a great place to come learn how
to trade because it's a lot of people
it's like speaking Greek as Shakespeare
once famously wrote probably it was him
other brokers charge up to $10.00 for
every trade but Robin Hood doesn't
charge a fee okay that adds up folks
it's designed to be easy to use and
understand they show you charts and
market data place a trade in just four
taps on your smartphone robin hood's web
platform also lets you view stocks
collections like 100 most popular
entertainment social media curated
categories like female CEOs which I am
fully diversified in and analyst ratings
of by hold cell for every frickin stock
it's the perfect place to learn to trade
learn how to invest as you build your
portfolio discover new stocks and track
favorite companies with personalized
news feeds custom notifications for
price movements so you never miss the
right moment to invest guys and hear
their offer is out of this world Robin
Hood is giving listeners one free stock
like Apple Ford or sprint to help build
your portfolio boom one free stock
that's cheddar cheese and the fricken
and the guac did that's guac and cheddar
in your bowl sign up at h3 podcast dot
Robin Hood dot-com that's h3 podcast dot
Robin Hood dot-com get started today
welcome back everybody to the h3 podcast
live thank you all for sticking around
back to the article I don't understand
this they start by saying Dallas him
what does that mean him well regardless
the most popular young artists and the
most unpopular young nation is a
rhinestone cowboy who looks like he
crawled out of a primordial swamp of
nacho cheese I'll hand that to him
that's pretty funny but post no mean
well okay he's making fun he says he
looks like he's a little sticky people
have said that a lot about him I can
tell you he doesn't stink but regardless
here it goes on this when it gets mean
post Malone is a Halloween rental a
removable Platinum grill cubic zirconium
proposal on the jumbo screen of a
last-place team
and get mileage out of that English
degree I know he's like that by the way
did I go mention I went to college
his music one of the shallowest
bastardization zuv rap to date and I do
not say that lightly I take it from mr.
Wein know what you would use basically
him saying I hate everybody
why is German for white I was literally
Jeff white yes Dan he's an authority
Authority on rap on the rap music your
last names a white dude mind your own
business
Dan said that not me I don't think I
don't see race as the creative tension
of associates at a downtown dude stop
with the analogy has the creative
tension of associates at a downtown law
firm complaining that $150,000 a year
just doesn't cut it
what are you talking about he looks like
he clubbed over that he looks like he's
clubbed over the head by cartoon peacock
he just turned 23
so panic all right dude this guy's so
bitter
he's so you could you could taste his
bitter and next America I just can't get
enough mm-hmm and somehow that's an
insult so well yeah because in his mind
the only reason that America get could
like this guy who he who went to college
and is so in tune with the hip-hop and
knows what's good the only reason the
only way that America could like him is
if you know the world was just upside
down enough that it's kind of like
Donald Trump did we mention and possibly
Nielsen recently named the suburban
Dallas raised rapper 2018 the most
popular musician so it's only a matter
of time before Malone had his own
festival a contemporary rite of passage
for nearly every major pop rap star who
has his face plastered across modifies
get turnt to playlist well I'm sure he's
on other playlists and get turnt more
like most popular songs about that one
[ __ ]
get turnt the inaugural postie fest was
held Sunday night and allyce's Dos Equis
pavilion
watch the like oh and did it have to be
on a beer a plate you say and it was a
less a festival than a behemoth
what is SAE do you know what that is dan
rush mixer held on a few acres of
corporate branded concrete many
festivals pride themselves on offering
non-musical diversity diversions such as
art installations or novelty culinary
options that sounds awful there were
none of that here though just $5 jello
shots that's exactly what I want when I
go to a show a novelty culinary option I
think the sae is a reference to a frat
by the way so he's just saying like okay
like a frat party
I think he's confusing a concert with a
farmers market the shot that concerts
that I usually go to remind me of
Calabasas farmers market there were a
little too sir there were a little
separated from a regular post one
concert other than the big-name opening
acts and True Religion sponsored post
Malone Ben dannis featuring extreme
close-up of Austin post itself glaze
squinting as ever what is wrong with
having a festival that's him plus other
big artists is at the point it's his
first festival you know it's not that
easy to put together you crazy through
that together so I know he was working
on a while I don't know what he's
comparing it to but maybe in five years
it would get crazier you know he's like
honestly compared to Lollapalooza this
thing sucks
there was no novelty arts and crafts
stations this should have ostensibly
been a coronation his unequivocal
ascension to the a-list pop superstardom
of mono named visionaries dude stop
there are artists who dictate the
zeitgeist and those who reflect it
post one is decided to lead the latter
an avatar of algorithm culture that
rewards pleasant banality over the
creatively vexing mmm I need to oh when
I'm listening to music I want to be
vexed I want to be confused oh it's like
you're trying to figure it out it's like
Oh what does it mean this guy needs to
be thinking all the time
sorry about my cough guys I'm still
getting over this illness when his own
festival miss hometown he had the
opportunity to lucidly state his mission
and values instead he revealed himself
to be Jack Johnson of the 808 and naked
Lee grafted hip hop's like I love that
he's like running for office okay guys
here's what I believe
eirick he didn't reject Trump and tell
everybody to vote you know what I mean
that's kind of what he's saying right he
had the opportunity to state his mission
and values mm-hmm like I feel like
that's what he's right he's like unlike
jay-z and Beyonce who say they hate
Trump and urge everyone to vote he
didn't actually want to say that but
that you know what the thing is that is
kind of why he's popular and I'll tell
you why because young kids they may
already have their mind up and they may
be politically motivated but this
article is part of the problem in that
it politicizes everything yeah and post
one is decidedly
unpolitical he said even two years ago
he doesn't vote and he's a young guy
okay first of all but like you it's nice
it is nice to separate politics from
some [ __ ] things yeah because it's
literally everywhere you know what I
mean you don't need to be preached to
all the effing time and is doing it as a
decision that's what he that's what he
wants and people like it yeah cause he's
trying to have fun because the point is
that he's trying to have fun and that's
his personality when you hang out with I
mean you know you don't have a political
conversation well this is just yeah but
ela you basically today right now on
this live podcast have the opportunity
to lucidly state your mission and values
so what do you believe in ela or are you
just a naked grifting hip-hop slag slag
slang by 9:30 p.m. chants of post e
filled the app amplitude er 15 year old
blonde girls and Daisy dude this guy was
there the whole time I guess he was
there taking every minute
like these yeah you know these youtubers
they've got a Jake Falcone yeah although
those guys are at least having fun
giving away this guy's like back there
with a notepad like look at all these
young kids having a good time
he didn't even state his values he
didn't even give us his mission
statement ours values he didn't even
tell me to vote postponed did not once
tell me to vote you know who this guy
has no friends by the way maybe he does
but they're all like I have a feeling
when their they have dinner parties in
for dessert they all lay in a circle
nose to ass and fart in each others face
it's like a cynic like okay you guys
ready for dessert let's all get in a
circle and then you put your nose right
in your your partner's ass and then you
fart dinner back into each other's face
because they like the smell of their own
farts as the joke arrogant is what I'm
trying to say
by nine-thirty chance of toast he filled
the amplitude her 15 year old blonde
girls in daisy dukes and champagnes and
blunts shirts shrieked as if postponed
were next to the lineage of Backstreet
Boys girls that I wanted to [ __ ] but
sadly will never have the opportunity
the Jonas Brothers or One Direction the
main difference this time is that they
honored their hero with matching
temporary face tattoos barbed wire on
the forehead a knife like crucifix on
the cheek and his trademark phrase inked
and cursive stay away and rest easy
temporary faces yeah I know bunch of
gang members with their faces that rose
in Troy Incan jerseys and beer bong
Bentley March merch grunted with Semien
Glee 20,000 people rocketed up stood on
their seats for a brief moment there was
the palatable fear of being stampeded to
death at postman concert which of course
requires the deceased to be buried in a
race car shaped coffin wrapped in the
Rockstar Energy Drink logo dude are you
trying to be funny
3 mm song served as his intro oh I love
that they make this about race watch
presumably a tacit nod to his fandom but
also a heavy-handed reminder that
postman was the most popular white guy
in hip-hop since Marshall Mathers
who the [ __ ] criticizes uh mmm at the
moment when the hysteria seemed in
danger of waning
post Malone took the stage to deafening
cheers scorching jet flames and
billowing clouds of smoke like a Groupon
version of a KISS concert in 1975 a
Groupon version first of all roof on
there's no Groupon version you when you
get Groupon you go see you can't get a
disco you got a disc you see kiss your
analogies are all twisted buddy you
should have said a dollar store version
yeah because Groupon gets you into the
show that was a weird one you know what
get them why me maybe you need to go
back and finish the degree big shot
Groupon version sipping from a Red Solo
Cup he soon began slurring too young mmm
it's like he's not he makes it sound
like he's so drunk he can't say anything
yeah
with a voice like bong water bubbling
and the casual misogyny of a member of a
red pill subreddit what the [ __ ] come on
so here you go a direct connection to
like some all right red pilling yeah
it's like dude that's in your mind
that's not what's there I actually can't
read it cuz he bleeped everything out
and I whipped fast my [ __ ] bad I guess
I skirt skirt that coupe fast my coop
fast your [ __ ] no my [ __ ] slow she'd
do what I say so and she always keep me
on my toes those lines are as good as
any representing what Malone is working
on a lyrical level I have to say if he's
picking out the most misogynist stick
red pill lyrics lyrics that ain't that's
not that persuasive because that's gonna
be a real task to start like looking at
lyrics so
hip-hop yeah yeah I mean and the truth
it like Kendrick Lamar who is applauded
by all has a great line and from his new
album where he says he's fears being
judged by his work his most bass lines
you know and if this is the best you
could find who that's not that's really
not convincing me that he's a red pill
subreddit you know on recording sis
falsetto is afforded a modest
four-cylinder strength but on stage it
comes off slurred and sloppy switching
like roadkill sweet twitching like
roadkill limp off-key notes underscored
by a booming backing track that operated
like a life preserver I'm going to get
effed up tonight who was effed up
tonight if I forget the words because
I'm too drunk help me sing along he told
the crowd it's the same applause line
that he used at Coachella his entire
setlist was essentially identical to
what he played at every festival all
summer long right down to the mono sila
syllabic curse laid in between song
babbling about haters and the importance
of rocking breaking up that's what
caught that's what's called a fad pretty
normal yeah smell the set dude if you're
like he's been doing the same thing for
10 years that might be interesting yeah
he's been doing the same thing all
summer
that's three months it's called a set he
tours a lot you got to know what you
know you got a set you guys hear that
the Rolling Stones played painted black
at their concert I love that post Malone
dared to come out with a set when I go
to festivals after I'm done with my arts
and crafts booth I like to enjoy spoken
word it's different every time as
perform as if as if the people coming to
a show don't want to hear the freakin
classics and by the way like I has two
albums it's all there mmm-hmm you know
what I mean even if his voice barely
slithered past the tenth Road it doesn't
matter fans who knew every word they
were there to commune to songs such as
better now his latest anthem and
interchangeable heartbreak presumably
made for streaming at the wahoos fish
tacos
LAX what the problem isn't necessarily
that it's crass but that it's
meaningless I thought he was crass that
I was a red pillar it's not that it's
stupid but it's vacant it's the losing
difference between appropriation and
outright theft whoo so there he's
actually accusing him not just of a
culture appropriation which is a high
charge enough but outright theft yeah
and by the way this music is only fit
for streaming at Wahoo's fish taco kiosk
at LAX did he get a kickback from the
taco kiosk the see this guy is involved
in big fish taco kiosk money by the way
I know this article upset him - because
he tweeted out [ __ ] you the same day it
came out mm-hmm which I presume was in
response to this article because you
know it's like dude he's not trying to
be anything he's not he's not trying to
be he's not being a fraud he's not being
a you know he's being authentic so if
you don't like it I understand it's not
for everybody but it seems to bother you
that everybody seems to like about you
but you have to make it seem like it's
the fabric that's tearing our country
apart and it's really not I personally
find articles like this to be more
damaging yeah than anything possible
mostly I decide his fault he's popular
he's doing what he's always done he's
making music he's likes people liked him
and they attached to him and they like
what he's doing it's not his fault he's
popular post it's like okay you didn't
cheat his way to the top he earned it
postman's music's dead I did an ignorant
astonish link dull and it's materialism
abandoned an abandoned lot of creativity
with absolutely no evidence of traffic
and his cerebral cortex ooh you are so
smart you are so smart and there's also
a negative side wait wait this was all
good
even if his intention is sincere homage
the blundering what what listen limit
imitation can't help but feel like
minstrel see I'm getting out bourbon
your be aged here weights like a
minstrel show like blackface kind of
thing mm-hmm right
while people will inevitably appropriate
the most culturally relevant music genre
one that's becoming almost entring
intrinsically bound to the modern comes
conception of pop but it's not asking
too much to attempt modest synthesis or
the incorporation of a single new idea
or at least to not be so grotesquely
desolate we went from mm to cheder Bob
shout out to cheddar Bob if post Malone
were black he wouldn't have sold half he
simply wouldn't exist there you have it
right here from Bob Y sips more and more
we don't and you get the idea yeah but I
just think it's just you know it's a
little dramatic what's most what's most
damning is post Malone's bloodless abyss
of soul and funk how do you have a
bloodless attempts at being emotional
feel like hollow gestures that goes on
and on I'm surprised there's not a
bull's-eye on his head you could go to
post most problem post most problem is
that he isn't a bad person or even
completely untalented thank you thank
you little tone ELISA I'll admit this
you're not completely untalented it's
that he stands for nothing at all I
think almost in a way good for him you
know
because music doesn't need to be
political yeah not everything needs to
be political he's an entertainer that's
supposed to be an escape he can afford
to feign the swagger and cool of hip hop
when it's convenient and opt out when
it's time to see who's riding for the
cause
it's always been a fairly
straightforward compact when it comes to
hip up if you're a white person eating
off of what has historically been black
culture you have a certain obligation to
repay that creative debt
mmm continues to attack the hypocrisy
and contradictions that allowed him to
leapfrog equally gifted artists that's a
strong statement Mack Laura may have
lacked subtlety or rudimentary
understanding of when to share text
messages but there are no questioning
his dedication of confronting his white
privilege even gez repeat even g-eazy
dropped out of that racist hmm
advertising campaign so here you have it
you know what more can you say
yeah possible so perfectly represents is
idiotic currents that have carried us
into this present cultural submersion
where an objective notion of the truth
has been systematically muddied what
that's not a stretch like come on like
right Trump lies their form post Malone
is popular facts are negotiable and any
hint of criticism be it for lacking
integrity dignity or talent can be
brazenly dismissed as the pitiful cries
of haters so congratulations I guess who
allowed this to happen what hole in the
system allowed this Greece discarded
barbecue wrapper to prosper a fake pale
King sitting on a tin foil throne return
to sender all right oh my god you're so
bitter dude I love how bitter you are
who allowed this guy to write pitchfork
he's like here's my English degree and
here's a list of all the I couldn't
believe how many it was when I was
reading it like that's what articles are
I feel like there's you know I feel like
there's a point to be made here I'm not
agreeing with it but I understand if
somebody wants to but like to make a
point but but myself but to be so mean
and comment made into an article right
it's like a elegant YouTube comment you
can make the point that like pop music
is vacuum but one you wouldn't be the
first person to make
point by a long shot and - it's not like
he's even like the biggest example of
that I mean you know he's comparing like
he compares him post unfavorably to one
direction and like Backstreet Boys it's
like that was just as vacuum like their
lyrics aren't [ __ ] deep what the [ __ ]
you talking about hit me baby one more
right the music they're like [ __ ]
fully bright at least he's a songwriter
exactly I'll admit he has some he's not
without Talent
I don't know the guy's just a dick he
just feels lighter and people who don't
know anything about him read this and
but you know what that's that's that's
part of the game the bigger you get yeah
it's part of the game but the good news
for postman long is that he's got a lot
of love and a lot of fans and it's funny
you say that because if you compare him
to his contemporaries in my opinion his
music is a cut above it is more it's
nicer it's better I think yeah whenever
we play like a random playlist of like
top top hits or whatever well I can't
stand most of them yeah I agree I mean
again he makes it seem like he owes a
debt to hip-hop and again that's a whole
theoretical debate I don't know but but
also what if you're gonna talk about
that his genre is not exactly him
exactly he's not really a rap merger he
does not have he doesn't what actually
he doesn't rap yeah he doesn't rap he
said even in the video they say his
biggest inspirations Bob Dylan yeah I
mean he's closer to rock and roll than
he is like hip-hop rap or like R&B maybe
on him but he doesn't anyway whatever so
there you go I read that and I was like
damn this is a dick yeah
and he's wrong and the thing is he's so
desperate to make it political because
most malone doesn't he's just not a
political guy and they hate that so if
anything you're the problem buddy
mm-hmm how many musicians are political
I mean there's a lot a lot art I mean a
lot a lot aren't a lot of them are
apolitical a lot of them just want to
stay out of it well the problem is that
he's poses with guns
spooky and he's from Texas extra spooky
so like a lot do speak but it's part of
this whole you know it's so obnoxious
man like let people be a political yeah
he can be on standing problem with that
just let him be like you don't have to
drag everybody into the fight if he
doesn't care about politics does he have
to force it like no as a young guy too
like he's focused on music he's not
reading about maybe later in his life
yeah he would care maybe he was exactly
no one needs to force it and like he
likes guns like again you can be on
either side of the spectrum and be pro
that doesn't mean he's not in favor of
sensible gun laws I don't know what his
political stance on that is what way or
the other but it's like let don't let
people be unpolitical maybe he votes and
maybe he cares about politics but like
just [ __ ] just the people that listen to
him want to chill anyway spoke enough
about that love only love to my boy post
Malone and he doesn't smell
he doesn't stink for the record he does
not stink I want to clear that up let's
clear the air well I haven't smelled him
there's no smell man put his mitten his
nose to his neck it's a good thing I
took a go X was good yeah dance he
hasn't washed his nose since all right
so guys it's time to play know your meme
that's right the biggest game on in the
world the biggest game in the world know
you're me yes today's guest is the old
the legendary run for the cube we've got
him
he's recorded 8 different phrases for
our lucky caller and they have to guess
what he said okay they got to get five
out of the eight correct to win a
brand-new Samsung Galaxy S nine plus a
retail value of $1,000 for our lucky
caller so let's get started here we go
we've got Chancellor on the line
Chancellor are you there hello you're on
the air
oh yeah Chancellor are you feeling lucky
today are you familiar with run the cube
run for the cute yeah I'm feeling lucky
pimp yes Chancellor I love to hear now
tell me about yourself where are you
calling from well I'm in Tyler Texas
all right and do you think you know what
I was gonna make a post Malone but let's
not get political here all right I like
post be going yeah no I like most you
too but I think I just talked about it
for like now tell me tell me uh
have you watched a lot of run for the
cube videos are familiar with his style
his delivery well without you guys this
video like four years ago I would never
have known about a special I've seen a
little bit of him but let me actually
you know familiarize our audience with
run for the cube really fast for those
who are oh wow this one has 13 million
views Wow
so he only shows this again coming
around that's right that's his classic
he only shows his hands green surgical
clubs and he takes a scalpel and
tweezers and dice X them as if they were
living creatures and he the agents of
his voice indicates that he has some
sadistic pleasure in it let's see we
have AG lime peel a peach ragout Mike
and I love a sex
a strong obsess with eyeballs brain
surgery so there you have it that is run
for the cube as I said run from the cube
is more more accurate in some cases but
what that being said Chancellor are you
ready to play yes I'm ready
all right hit me with the tension let's
start from the top
no what is he saying here we go are you
mine are you yes there what did you hear
do I have options or you what do you
think I'll play one more time plan on
options the thing is if I give you
multiple choice that'll be too obvious
the guys speak in English I'll play
Chancellor I'm gonna play for you one
more time okay okay here we go listen
closely
alright what did you hear Chancellor oh
my gosh gibberish I thought he said
something about are you crying at the
beginning of kalbi person is your hint
[Music]
chancellor coming on the board strong of
course hey hey come on together okay we
got to navigate this guy now let's move
it on to round 2 are you ready
hmm I'm ready as I'll ever be
all right here we go Chancellor well he
said yes newbies [ __ ] how you w-well
Ethan
yes yes yes yes what did you hear any
words I think I heard eat then in there
hmm
here I'll give you an end Michelle Obama
okay and that doesn't yeah Wow Ethan
great man you want to play it again
because I'm okay yeah I see it written
so yeah maybe I know maybe it maybe yeah
yeah it's one of those like optical
illusions where if you see it and then
you hear it like the yeah the one that
was anyways well here we go because I
thought those two were going to be easy
and this one freebies alright well you
got to close no you only need to get
three more right so you've got all the
chances okay what do you got here I'm
here in my garage just bought my new
Lamborghini you're understanding you're
entering the cube yeah getting put on
you yes guys all of us do run for the
cube and get I hope you have your green
surgical gloves on and your scalp all
ready because we are moving on
[Music]
that's a tough is it can I get it one
more time or the hands or something I
think I might have something but well
what do you think him well I heard a
lighter I love it I like it mm-hmm and
where does that lead you there was more
I thought that's all he said there were
three words okay and there's a few with
it one more time there you go three
words I love ah three words I love time
is running out
oh no Hank I love I gave you two of the
three words that is a hint here we
videos we've made yes all right I think
we're out of time
do you have a final answer yeah yeah
okay uh oh I love memes that's all I got
so the real answer was I loved Vic
connects made famous by of course that's
okay you're three out of four which is
very good
that's a X that's a excellent record
here we go this one is gonna be tough so
listen closely as if you are performing
surgery on a rodents eyeballs attention
and clarity and focus so here we go I
might be from be free wow he's more like
you than he said I'm watching from the
furnace
[Applause]
all right of course he is as all good
men are waking from the front that is
right it's incorrect you want to live
with the balls and perform a scooping
motion as an open discussed at great
length windows gloves yes with the green
glue so what are we at right now I
believe you're at it's four to one he
needs one more needs one more all right
I got to tell you because there's yeah
there's mine there's three more so how
long chances we got a lot of chances
here don't [ __ ] this up here we go you
need a few what are you looking forward
to getting a new Samsung do you need the
phone yeah kind of I drop mine and
cracked it up pretty bad recently yeah
yeah yeah yeah is it I phone no it's a
note eight you're in the club so you see
you Marty in the same fun game but it's
yeah well good we're gonna get rid of
that hopefully you got three chances
left
hopefully yeah you know we're gonna lock
this down as record I will say in your
favor
nobody has ever lost a round of know
you're me hey can you guys sign the
phone if I do winning yeah yeah just
write on the glass give you some germs
yeah blah use a sharpie and cover they
don't be counting your eggs yet I know I
know I'm getting the hope they'll be
counting your gummy worms yet I wasn't
looking at the words and have no [ __ ]
idea what he said we played again okay
are you slamming yeah this donut is
slamming dude Wow
the great green not only you are a
winner you have completed the challenge
Chancellor to be the brand new Samsung
Galaxy S 9 plus it feels good honestly
if I would have lost I still would have
been happy to just talk to you guys so
sweetheart I kind of want to continue we
have so we play though ice - I've got a
lot yeah by all means let's go these are
the bonus rounds if you don't get all
three murders whatever you like I do
prefer yeah really it's either one okay
so here we go for every one you get
correct from here you get something you
get another item there you [ __ ] go
okay here we go
no it's okay this is the but this is the
super okay that's fair this is it okay
here we go
one great clip of millionaire the first
guy that one wants to be a millionaire
he goes I want to use the last lifeline
to call my dad to tell him I won you got
that swag I love that all right well you
won what would you like what do you want
you want to be surprised that's one item
um well let's go ahead I'll take this
one and then if I win the second one
then I'll have you guys surprise me all
right I would love to have one of the
fascinating shirt all right there we go
win another item are you ready I'm ready
you're crushing it man you're crushing
it here we go
try to click it well you do like you to
ply a quite gammy for a quite kind will
you do like you to play a quick game it
must be no close family day because he
says we play a quick game for a quick
[Applause]
[Music]
Wow
such an exciting day got so much
happening so proud tell me what are you
gonna do now that you've won are you
going to Disneyland oh man I'm gonna go
tell everyone that I know every one of
my friends have watched you guys I want
to be bragging all week okay well
Chancellor stay on the line I want to
thank Dona calling in you're a great
awesome to it appreciate you being a fan
of the show we're gonna hook you up with
fascinating and a surprise item and the
Samsung which you have won you've earned
here today thank you so much appreciate
you and have a blessed blessed Friday
and a great weekend thanks for calling
thank you alrighty thanks guys and
congratulations on the baby
thank you and of course I want to thank
run for the cube who was gracious to
participation of legend I appreciate all
of our memes who are legends in their
own right who come and lend their
expertise to us and love love love love
love love so thank you run for the cube
Wow that was thrilling should it's
always really fun I love those I can't
believe that we got him yeah I know all
the people he's flown for the queue
that's right we've got a lot more to get
to my goodness we've got quite a episode
here my dudes almost blessed Friday so
next up is the we've got the mom let me
see here I've got Kanye but actually
we were gonna do harassed the teacher
suing her student let me do that first
and then we'll have Ian hop in here to
give us a Kanye update Kanye moves at
light speed a lot goes on in that man's
life so this is a story that blew my
mind and listen I'm not look I just
this is not like a social justice thing
I'm not okay I'm not that's not my angle
here I want to say I'm genuinely
confused by this I'm just I'm perplexed
I'm vexed in the words of the great Baba
Weiss who wrote that article about post
Malone I'd like to be vexed at my
concerts
I'd like to be like that why relax into
music videos on BuzzFeed and it is about
a teacher who is suing I believe the age
was 13 still suing her thirteen year old
student for making fun of her in class
for being gay I guess I don't know it's
really hard to tell from the video but
it's so strength the whole story is so
strange and I just find it strange
bizarre that BuzzFeed is taking this
approach like they're doing a
journalistic video but it really doesn't
answer any questions and doesn't yeah
and it's just it's why it's a wild ride
that I want to take you guys on so with
that being said let us enjoy I was
harassed by my student for being gay on
BuzzFeed video but I'm also the first
teacher
to volunteer to go pie to the face or an
egg cracked on my head like whatever it
is to reward students one of the
highlights of my job is the fact that I
probably laughed cry like at least once
a day because teenagers are funny and if
you let them be funny they're really fun
[Music]
such you drinking pal I green oh wow
it's fancy for a schoolteacher I mean
obviously you have to note that she
looks the part you have to note it looks
something we're all thinking it
just saying she has a look she has a
specific look okay moving on don't have
to note it but yeah other thing is that
we're all looking at her and being like
all right you know what I mean yeah
there's something going on there she's
got a specific look you know that's okay
like if I saw someone walking around and
like a Pikachu hat and like a reflective
Leste and huge enhance I'd be like oh
that guy's a raver
you know what I'm saying she's got a
look that's all you have an eighth grade
English teacher I've been teaching for
about 12 years now how the school system
I've impacted a student or had a good
day in the classroom is really
indescribable because while education
does not necessarily pay well what it
does pay is knowing that you've had a
chance to impact future generations my
goal is always to really understand
where students College just bear in mind
well did well they're showing this in
her being all like triumphant in great
she's still suing a 13 year old student
mm-hmm I just find that those that
dichotomy over like those two things
yeah you're suing a 13 year old like
what person not justice I don't know I
don't know this is so weird I guess
because he he harassed her but the
example she give doesn't seem that bad
it's more like for bullying her not
harassed I guess but I guess what I do
use to over not pay me you do great my
story begins at the start of the
2017-2018 school year I had several
students approached me privately
of concern to let me know that a former
student of mine who was following me on
Instagram because they wanted to keep in
touch with me had taken a photo of me
and my partner and posted it to her
Instagram and let my current students
know that I was gay prior to that I had
never discussed my sexuality in the
classroom intentionally because I know
that I teach in a very conservative
climate and it wasn't something that I
felt I needed to share right off the bat
with students as the affair that's a
road fall somebody and picture them with
their partner yeah and I can't imagine
that's gonna be hard to be a teacher I
mean you know it's so weird when I was a
kid there was no social media like I can
imagine like stalking your teacher and
taking photos and then sharing it with
all your classmates on Instagram like
god that's messed up and kids can be
mean Oh kids are straight up Eve
especially 13 that's like the most evil
a-absolutely they're all every 13 role
is a freaking psycho I mean the worst
thing you the worst thing I ever did to
a teacher when I was in high school I
think it was our principal because
you're such a douche we like TPT's house
it's pretty rad it's not that it's not
that bad is it we followed him home and
we're like we found know where he is
we're gonna TP his house [ __ ] I did what
they're talking about in this I took
pictures and see really yeah but there
was no there was no one [ __ ] myspace
right like what did you take photos with
oh I had a camera when I was a kid and
then we just like draw nasty [ __ ] on it
make fun of you this is like amongst
friends this is about sharing it with
the world if you drew a funny picture of
a photo and that everyone at the school
saw right it just amplifies at times a
thousand right yeah yeah so anyway I'm
sympathizing me to let me know that this
was really a hot topic on the Internet
it was a hot topic on campus and people
were continuing to discuss it I went to
my administration multiple times I mean
in this day and age I can't I have a
hard time seeing that the back oh she's
gay maybe I'm wrong though she says
she's a very conservative area so I can
yeah it could be hard probably but
also you're kind of the adult in the
situation mm-hm
well at any rate I'm not judging her yet
let's watch ya know that I was concerned
about this and I felt like things were
getting out of this shot I've heard just
walking the earrings just like and the
initial response was that this was bad
this is the word that was used and that
it would die down and to be fair I hoped
so too unfortunately that's not what
occurred okay so she says everyone hoped
there was drama would die down so it's
not what occurred so what's leading me
to believe is that somebody's like
started writing like slurs on the door
or like keying her car or some [ __ ] like
hate crimes right let me fix my mic here
okay so let's see what happens during
that school year I was also pursuing my
Master of Arts degree I had to maintain
an online YouTube channel where I
responded and reflected on things that I
had read or activities I've completed
one night I noticed that a flood version
started to follow me on that account and
then I received a comment that said
don't be stupid be a smarty you can join
the not-see party
now accepting died so that I can't
this comment on YouTube this is what she
said sadly it didn't end there
she had one person write a roué comment
on youtube we're getting like 10 times
it's like are you kidding me one every
five yeah every personal every defect I
have as a person is apparently it's
almost a relief for me to know that
every negative attribute of my of my
personality is because I'm Jewish and
that really actually takes the load off
I thought I was just like yes I can't do
anything right yeah no I thought I had a
like a lot of development and maturing
to do but it turns out I'm just a Jew
it's kind of a relief honestly but so
this this what happened is this comment
sets her off down it thank you so weird
cuz it doesn't even seem personal like
to obviously honestly as someone who's
been on the receiving end of of shitty
comments like
it's not that bad yeah it's not personal
and it's kind of like it's kind of just
a stupid thing because it's like the
Nazis are accepting dykes like that
doesn't even make sense yeah it's just
being cheeky
obviously rude and I under what I
understand being upset by it but what
happens is it sets her off on this
personal crusade of trying to find out
who wrote this comment a comment on
YouTube so now she goes on like this
warpath and that's what was going on my
mic okay it's why is this thing not a
little droopy dude I don't understand
why is it they got pills for that we're
that is your mic droopin drooping all
over the place dude all right this is
where the podcast is good so anyway she
goes so if she just ignored the comma
and she like she said it's just drama
it'll die down but she goes on this
warpath to say who wrote that comment
and this is ends up being her demise as
far as I can tell but like here we go I
immediately took a screenshot and sent
it to my administration and asked them
to sit down with me it took my
administration of four months to be
principal being like what do you want me
to do it yeah it may not even send
someone at your school it's one youtube
comment so like she X she sent it to the
principal and she's like you haven't
suspended anybody yet well anyway here
let it this shut up I'm gonna play the
video I did that immediately sent it off
to them and unfortunately they decided
that they didn't like the direction of
the lesson and I was told that it would
occur later on once someone else had a
chance to review it I had started to
experience some severe depression and
even more severe anxiety about being in
class because I felt like I didn't know
what was being said about me or what was
being done and I also felt like I wasn't
being support
or kept safe the way that I believe I
deserve to
so is this bananas this one comment now
all the sudden she's she's I think it's
just not the right job for her being a
teacher is tough you gotta have like
really tough skin no you know especially
like we said with their middle school
teachers yeah nobody going in as a gay
teacher in a conservative area you kind
of have to know this would happen
and you she didn't know and she
purposely kept it yeah you know there's
a chance that someone will find out so
yeah I was surprised she was a teacher
for 12 years I never encountered
anything like but I just find it's you
she said she taught for Toya and she had
a meltdown over one youtube comment and
I just imagined like print that carrying
a print of it to that principal and
being like you need to do something
about this it's like what it's like I
even if you sympathize it's like what do
you want me to do trace the IP yeah call
the cyber police and so I I can only
imagine what that presentation look like
that they vetoed mm-hmm they're probably
just like you're gonna make it a
presentation over one random comment and
also you're gonna get worse yeah okay
everybody I saw this comment calling me
a dyke and saying I that the Nazi Party
is accepting and I want to know who was
it and I put together presentation
that's like inviting all don't feed the
trolls as they famously say yeah
but okay bye and during a presentation
one of my students made some disparaging
comments about gay marriage which
elicited quite a response from my
students a lot of excitement and looking
at me and definitely awaiting a reaction
after that upon reviewing the students
written work I noticed that some more
derogatory comments were used about gay
people in her work and I brought that
again to the attention of my
administration and my administrators
felt like the best course of action
there was simply a teachable moment I
contacted my union at that point from
there and asserted to me getting a
regional rep involves for my Union who
eventually hired me a lawyer
just imagine wanting to expel a student
it's like your room you're trying to
ruin the kids of life it's like you're
the adults I know they said something
really mean and rude and homophobic
they're 13 okay they're pretty ignorant
but I fact if she took it in a different
way
maybe she to tell me yeah maybe she
could have turned it into exactly
something that would teach them like
what do be let's talk about it what you
through what it why did you say that
what do you think yeah but and then the
principal actually seems like pretty
cool like even headed about it but like
money like what does she when she's like
this person wrote something homophobic
she's like Alfre blood like you have to
expect like the [ __ ] you know you're
going after a kid man I mean they didn't
threaten her or do anything like totally
insane it says then the realm of normal
child behavior to be a douche
due to anxiety and depression Amy took a
mental health leave from teaching her
case is currently being litigated for
what I haven't been in the classroom
since January and I would say that there
are two things that I missed the most
first and foremost I love picking grass
man it's like a commercial or depression
she's just out there picking grass she's
not in the classroom anymore educators
in terms of students and very sad that I
didn't get to read Fahrenheit 451 with
them or be there for their eighth grade
graduation it was really challenging for
me to miss out on both of those things
I don't feel frustration or anger
towards students I think that as
teenagers were always you know they're
growing and they're changing and they're
formulating their own opinions the onus
really lies on the adults in the system
to do better and that's what I feel most
disappointed in I don't even feel anger
towards the adults in the situation I
think that you know my ultimate hope is
that everyone learns and grows so that
we understand what the close-up man is
BuzzFeed shots way too close up
show me the earring jiggling and picking
grass next time a situation like this
occurs we create a culture where she's
got a part of plural bead what do you
call that Dan used to be a raver right
big stapler oh sorry
peace love unity respect right yeah you
got a dude you're not the only one this
parted i'm pleure for life baby
and again oh if you walked out of screen
we reached out to a me school for
comment we include an excerpt from the
response in the description you don't
want to show it to too many people okay
so she she's suing the school not not
the student is that my why I thought it
was the student but it doesn't actually
say it says yeah it doesn't say it says
the litigation is ongoing I would think
it's if you anything it's just cool I
don't know why I thought it was a kid
I'm not reading that somewhere but I am
an idiot I just don't understand what
the school cut why I don't understand
what the litigating is for I don't
understand why any pain I don't even
understand why this is a video at all
yeah like there's no story here I was
how is her making a youtube channel even
under the responsibility of the school
exactly exactly
it's YouTube do people can find your
videos yeah and did she say she was she
made the YouTube channel for the
master's degree that she was trying to
get so this is like an extra trick this
doesn't even have to do with her work
how did she even know it was a student
who made exactly the statement from the
school is boring it's very just what you
would expect to be very legal but I just
I wonder why this video even exists
there's no information nothing happened
as far as I can tell it's like what that
what are you trying to prove with this
video she's up there kids are [ __ ]
like that's it she got us good yep God
yeah in this day and age I was such a
dick to my teachers you know and they
you know they they were adults about it
they just moved on every time some one
of my students insults me I want their
life ruined and them to be expelled from
school and to have to switch schools I
want them in prison I want them in
juvenile hall for any crime so there you
go
I don't know BuzzFeed is like it's like
- did you you didn't even have to make
this vid there's a no story they just
they had this artistic vision for the
closer
they're like we start with the close-ups
and we build around I had this vision of
a bouncing hearing at you shall be
handpicking grass there you have it
folks I don't know why we should do we
have to change the title yeah we kind of
I was thinking the same thing yeah y'all
got baited not as spicy no I'm not as
spicy but still pretty spicy what else
we got Kanye is back at it and you want
to come you want to come
decode Kanye decoded I'm sending him in
here we go here comes Ian let me play a
song I got a song here where is it here
we go
dang am in Dan I don't want to with my
mic but it's drooping like my frickin
like everything like it's giving me
flashbacks I don't need this my face did
how do I fix this hey Ian hey having
Mike issues mine's very this very virile
Mike oh yeah yeah young man you're a
young man no it is also sick there you
go now I popped a couple Edie's right
how's the sound right now you sound good
really is any supposed to be no that
one's less directional yeah just popped
a couple I took more than directed in
how are you today
god bless and good ei good afternoon
there's something about that you
immediately want to touch and like I
know
non-stop yeah I'm doing good I'm I'm
back there coffin to and you know place
is a [ __ ] petri dish of the Ebola now
before we get into this I want to say
congratulate you I heard the great news
you've been made an honorary moderator
of our Kanye the subreddit
which is that's a that's a huge
community yeah they told me this morning
oh so congratulate thank you thank you I
know those guys another Kanye community
is very important to you how do you feel
about being given this honorary title I
feel like the Queen kind of because
because he was like you don't have to
actually moderate we don't it kind of
was like we don't want you to don't
touch anything it's like we want to put
your name there and Wow
that's cool it's good they don't want me
to start banning people and yeah digging
around sure but yeah so I'm movin i jus
lations I feel you're getting street
cred you're getting acknowledge for for
yeah and there was also the invitation
to the Kanye podcast yeah which is
coming up what's the name and when is
that happening so people can tune in uh
it's on the 10th I believe next I'm
gonna record it I don't know when he
puts it out but it's called watching the
throne watching the throne
yeah the premiere Kanye West's podcast
in fact Kanye himself follows them on
Twitter a recent development which has
led us to believe that Kanye is a fan of
Ian it's been fun has happened with the
purple hat and everything so
congratulations I'm waiting so Ian's
gonna be against yeah yeah I'll be on
there watching the from it's only a
matter of time until I get a knock on my
door I open it and there's Kanye hmm
someday he'd be a great guest for me I
joked about I said if Kanye ever comes
on here as a guest
Ian's are gonna sit here I'm not gonna
say [ __ ] I'm not gonna be in the room
I'm just gonna maybe I'll sit there and
work out yeah that kind I'll just I'm
not gonna say [ __ ] watch these two talk
but be that as it may there's been a lot
of Kanye developments actually is this a
good place to start in uh yeah this is
he tweeted this out he's trying to kind
of clarify his beliefs political beliefs
a little bit probably got tired of all
the heat he was getting lots of heat
lots of heat friends and family you know
dumping him yeah but he didn't really
like I know I read these tweets and
these this
mean much to ya let me read yeah go
ahead I would like to thank my family
loved ones and community for supporting
my actual beliefs in my vision for but
is this before after he disavowed this
is before okay so I support those who
risked their lives to serve and protect
us and I support holding people who
misuse their power accountable I believe
in love and compassion for people
seeking asylum and parents who are
fighting to protect their children from
violent Wars I support creating jobs and
opportunities for people who need them
the most
I swore prison reform I support
common-sense gun laws that will make our
world safer what I see this as because
this is a lot of liberal kind of Left
linking meaning beliefs and I think he's
trying to reach out and be like hey I
don't disagree with you on these points
I just like Donald mm-hmm yeah yeah I
think he's trying to which is what do
I've said before is he's not like a you
know heavy political guy a lot of this
is kind of vague too I mean like you
know that's true
I support holding people who misuse
their power accountable that's like a
fun thing to say but I don't know what
that means I see it as me to stuff oh
okay
or like Wall Street stuff too but
regardless it does heat up as he lives a
lot of room for interpretation does so
here we go I so now there was a thing
called Blake what is blogs it he he's
had this woman around him for a while
called Candace Owens she's kind of a
right-leaning
political figure and she's been very
close with him kind of ever since he put
the hat on and like in his circle going
wherever he's going she's always around
interesting and so she has this thing
called black sit I hate saying them it's
like it's not good yeah it's not how do
you say elegant to say no legs it and it
flex it right black say I mean but I
mean that's if you're trying to like
combine the two words that actually well
brexit what the plan breaks it yeah well
because you need to exit it's like the
exit but yeah it's like the the black
exit from
the Democratic Party is what she wants
she wants everyone to leave in mass and
so she put out merch and told people
that Kanye designed it and I think that
was kind of the breaking point which
sparked all of this here's the logo in
question actually and also I will say
and not a very well designed
looks like someone's being crucified in
the parlor and Jim merch
yeah it looks like some of my camp
counselor would wear and not very not
very spicy no it's not great and so
after that happened he came out and was
like no I didn't do that
yeah and you're you had an interesting
theory about about that I think yeah all
of this everyone thinks oh he's like
come to his senses
oh he's realized the error of his ways I
think he just didn't want to be
associated with a shitty design right I
think that's it he's like I'm not
offended at all by your political
beliefs I just - its weak yeah I don't
want anyone to think that I put my name
on that yeah what he said in response to
this design was actually something that
had got a lot of attention a lot of
people interacted with us we'd have like
hundreds of thousands of likes and
retweets and here it is he said my eyes
are now open and I now realize I've been
used to spread messages I do not believe
in I am distancing myself from politics
and completely focusing on being
creative and that blex it logo was wack
he said yeah and the one before well he
said essentially he had nothing to do
with it yeah so what do you make of this
is this a genuine and I saw when this
tweet came out I just immediately
started everywhere like everyone
thinking that it's about Trump yeah
well that's what I assumed that it was
about like hey yeah I mean that's really
the only assumption to make really oh
that's why yeah there's so many likes
and everyone immediately went Oh fine so
he's back to you know yeah just chilling
now and that means he doesn't like
Republicans at all I think that was
jumped in which isn't the case because
he clarified with TMZ which is the next
thing
but his sameness so dramatic my
mean anything else when he says my eyes
are now wide open mmm it's like I've
just I've been awakened to this great
misfortune you know yeah I think it goes
back like with the first few tweets I
think he does it on purpose he leaves
things big and interesting so here we
have what do we have here so this is
from the TMZ article they reported it
and their headline was something like
Kanye is done with Trump uh-huh and then
he reached out to TMZ right away and it
said Kanye contacted us to make it clear
he did not mention Donald Trump in his
tweets and he's getting out of politics
altogether as for being used he says he
was specifically referencing blacks and
that's it so interesting so it kind of
lets see there's no there isn't more
well is this just more is there anything
genuine going on here or is this just
more of kind of this Kanye trying to
drum up attention what do you make of
this he's what's happening here part is
the honorary moderator of Archon
speaking for the subretinal Kanye fan
now honestly I think that this may be
why I have the flu here I'm worn out I
mean it just I just want the album at
this point you know it's it's it's
twenty days away is it well he's got a
little it comes out I don't know
and then I can't take what he says I
don't know if he means it like when he
goes I'm done with politics maybe that's
this week and then he's gonna debut it
and he's gonna have the maggot hat on
again yeah and I you know it seems that
that's a common theme yes oh yeah we we
need a segments we getting power pole
krycek
it seems to be a common segment among
his sentiment among his fans that it's
like we're getting tired of this just
give us the music yeah and i and i i
don't also he can believe whatever i
don't care about that but you know
keeping track of it all like you said
it's like this whirlwind it's nonstop
mm-hmm he's always in the news there's
always things going on it's kind of
tiring right also there was a thing this
week with easy as being like available
for everyone now we're following that
yeah what was that he because he said a
while ago that he wants eventually to
make it available for everyone that's
production sells out and then you're
gonna go to resellers interesting so now
I think it was available but then people
were reporting that it's not doing that
well and they wonder if it's because of
the drama or which one all of the past
models are the new black one well there
there were the last the release before
the last one was the biggest one he's
ever done he's the most wide release
ever so there were gonna be shoes
available but people took that as oh
everyone hates Kanye now my yeah but
it's just they that's the money that
ever made or shoes yeah and I think it's
the same case with the new release to
got it but I did see a few people
reporting oh yeah that's because every
yeah well you are wearing a pair you
know not right now right now already
posed like eases are finally for
everyone and no one cares you don't care
and then yeah they make it about
politics of course and there you go well
Kanye is political so I guess but you
know well Ian we thank you for keeping
us updated on the world of home yeah I
know it's a complicated stuff keeping up
with the Kardashian yeah do you think
that Kim's reality stardom has affected
Kanye in the sense that he saw Oh
Keeping Up with the Kardashians
everybody cares about this kind of
real-life drama is that something that
may be bled off in the Kanye know I
think he's always had a talent for this
and I think that's why they're so great
there's these marketing machines right
yeah so you know Ian stay tuned keep
your ear to the grind stone is that a
saying is that what they say I don't
think so hey what do you keep your ear
towards you your ear to the ground
o ear to the ground keep ear to the
ground in I'll go listen to the grind
but listen ever one grindstone on
on the other in thank you so much thank
you
where's the song sorry everyone think
I'm trying to not breathe yeah don't
break the other in the intern everybody
we love in the intern he's wonderful guy
he's assets at the show and boy boy
where would we be without him would know
a lot less about Kanye that's for sure a
twitch
we've got a twitch streamer hood a great
little clip this is kind of funny
because this guy is not even a big
streamer oh man oh no nevermind it's not
a race he's not even a big streamer
that's what makes it so great oh my god
this Twitter clip has over 3 million
views I am but because what he says is
just so and he's a twitch streamer that
has like well I don't know how big he is
on Twitch but he's got like 5,000
Twitter followers so I mean when I look
for streamers that I I want to relate to
them I want them to be witty I want them
to be cool I want them to have that
unique aspect that all of us strive to
have but I need my coughing super loud
in the mic cuz I keep turning away but I
want to make sure I'm not ear raping
everybody it's helping okay but turn
more if you can yeah because I don't
want to talk to a [ __ ] wall
okay but well part of the thing for me
is I specifically don't want my viewers
to have any kind of relationship with me
so like that's like it kind of works out
right I'm kind of like I'm hitting my
goal but um I'm shutting everybody out
that's kind of a bad strategy which I
don't know I kind of I'm doing a
livestream and I don't want to be
connected to anybody maybe make videos
no you totally are
and as weird as that sounds and it's
like it's kind of like low key like god
complex kind of thing is I don't feel
like many of my viewers should relate
themselves to me because and this is
like super like kind of like I got like
kind of weird is like I do think of
myself as
better than or not better but like
bigger no good way to say this I think
of myself as like above the average
person so I don't feel like many people
could relate to me as like bad as that
sounds I know why worry about what like
what would even if you're so superior
and intelligent and like 220 IQ huge
Rick and Morty fan why would you think
that was a good idea to say he sounds
like such a prick you're just a [ __ ]
like also he's like not even a big deal
on twitch and it's got like 11,000
followers you know I just want to say I
just want to say this and I don't want
you to take the wrong way but I do have
11,000 followers on Twitter and I do
think and again this comes off bad but I
am superior to in every way
yeah I mean how many followers do you
have on Twitter what like what 200 I
mean
case in point you're [ __ ] pathetic
damn this guy got reamed for this video
how did he think that that could be
anything award saying also I like how he
keeps referring to I was like a gum god
complex low-key guy complex it's like
well that he knows that it sounds bad
it's like yeah I did because it is bad
but I feel like he's flattering himself
in a way of like saying he has a god
complex too because again you know
you're not even just fight you can't
even have a god complex when you have
11,000 Twitter followers like imagine
imagine that guys are God yo I am some I
do I am somewhat of a god complex I feel
like a god complex so they're like has
it twitch and apparently there was a
ecology video
there's no good way to say this I think
of myself as like above the average
person so I don't feel like many people
could relate to me as like bad as that
sounds I know [ __ ] idiot
there's alright there you go
there you have it mmm nice oh this story
is fantastic
Elia you're gonna love this specifically
you look porn watching employee infected
government network with Russian
malware's let the [ __ ] fat government
auditors traced a malware infection back
to a single porn watching employee
within the US geographical survey an
interior department watchdog recommended
the u.s. geographical survey ratchet up
Internet security protocols after
discovering its network had been
infected with malware so I guess there's
like a government agency network that
kind of connects everything and they
have really strict rules about what how
you can use the internet because that's
we're so slick that Russia they're like
banking on the fact that some boys
eating off at work I just did you ever
like put on porn at work like why would
you do that I'll say this I'll say that
you have a lot of downtime at work you
can't have a lot of downtime or okay it
says that he reportedly used the
computer to visit 9,000 adult video
sites that's all [ __ ] that's a lot
like if I'm browsing reddit you know at
work and my my desk is facing the wall
mm-hmm
it's like yeah you see some titties on
the homepage and you part you probably
you probably you take a look but you're
done doing it you're not now I'm not
downloading porn videos not like
augmenting my catalogue
this guy's like on [ __ ] pornhub like
downloading [ __ ] they said 9,000 is yeah
how do you want and that's that's his
job watching porn is his job I don't
know what he does for the geographical
services that's not just popping over to
pornhub like that are you asking if I
got my dick out and masturbate no you
look yeah that's what I'm asking but I
did cuz where is it going exactly that's
why I don't like watching porn at work
because it's like I'm not some people
watch porn like it's like a cooking show
for me it's very when I put it on let's
be frank I'm cleaning the pipes getting
the poison out as they say and so it's
like that's kind of the reason why I
don't understand go into a strip club
it's like okay I've never been to a
strip club and I really have no interest
because it's like okay yeah what do you
do go home and beat off that's the same
thing I was gonna do anyway save the
money watch some porn and download some
Russian malware but you got it you got
to admire the ingenuity of these Russian
like cyber warriors putting like putting
ads on porn sites with malware I mean
that's yeah and crazy that's amazing I
love by the way there's like digital
detectives they they go our digital
forensic examination revealed that the
employee had an extensive history of
visiting adult pornography websites the
hosted malware a rope the malware was
downloaded to the employees government
laptop which then exploited the USGS
network isn't that awesome mm-hmm
this is the best episode of CSI ever the
employee no longer works at the agency
yeah imagine trying to get his next job
and he had a good run having to say why
he was firing his next job you can host
a porn site he's got 9,000 videos do you
have a recommendation of me like his
next job interview oh yeah so tell me
what part do you like over the last 15
years similar scandals have enveloped
the Environmental Protection Agency
Securities and Exchange Commission's and
IRS
last year a DC area News Network
uncovered egregious on-the-job
pornography viewing at a dozen federal
agencies and national security officials
have reportedly found an unbelievable
amount of child pornography
wowthat's threw me off I didn't expect
that on government devices what [ __ ]
hell who are these people watching child
porn and downloading it and they work at
the government [ __ ] this problem maybe
yeah this problem is so prevalent that
Rep mark meadows has introduced
legislation banning pornography at
federal agencies three different times I
don't think you need a what's the
legislation gonna do
Scott damn it you guys not much porn on
your government computers and putting
national security at risk that's amazing
I hope that in 15 years there's like a
there's a story like a movie about this
not like how the russians hacked it
online guy watching porn dumbass
downloading porn but I bet you ela of
people that have private offices have a
lot of them have be it off at work yeah
it's the know they do a report yeah well
of course I mean you're not gonna beat
off in front people it's kind of nuts
isn't it yeah don't like dude right here
you just like this we've seen those
videos of people doing in the library
yeah that's what I mean those guys are
deranged I don't have to say you have
seen videos of like drifters who come in
and just start beating it in the library
it's like magic mean that depraved
though you see some titties and you're
like all right take my dick out yes yes
of course we made it to our wall man I
want to finish what we've got goddamn it
this is a lot male bummers car whatever
I don't care about that anymore children
fright club don't really care about it
that much yeah Judge Dredd pretty cool
parking intentionally Brett oh this one
I like this one I need to show you guys
party intentionally breaks the floor and
everybody falls through now before I
show you this I want to tell you that I
read that there was no life-threatening
injuries and no fatalities as a result
of this which is surprising when you
look at the footage of a so horrific but
it is hilarious and especially when you
learn when you read the article is that
they felt the ground shaking and they
were trying to break it now that's a
party turning up I don't know how to
view it and so where'd they placed in
the screen yeah but um hopefully you can
make that out don't fullscreen the
window just drag it to the one to the
right a little bit oh yeah is that good
perfect okay
so [ __ ] hell so these guys are like
whoa the grounds all wobbly and so
everybody starts jumpin an attempt to
actually [ __ ] break it and so here
they go having the time of their life
and whoopsie-daisy say nice oh my god
and now some of the people if you watch
like some look so it then yeah but I
mean there's like what a hundred people
some of the people slanted standing up
to one dude in the white shirt you'll
see he landed he's like yeah watch this
guy in the white shirt here right here I
think he slides down and he's just like
right here he's like what the [ __ ] it's
crazy huh so there you have it like the
commentary just yo that guy just almost
fell through the ground by the way I
love that he's like everyone like the
guy right in front of him falls into an
abyss he's literally at the edge and
he's like all right is the presence of
mind to just keep rolling yeah and we
think the frame what a legendary can
starts a new video like when you be
panicked when you want to get out of the
room at that point like maybe more of a
cloud you know why you'll never
I love it I just love that they were
trying to do it no that's lady drives
through marathon you know it's just a
bunch of ID's I'll save it I want to
watch a lot of these with Tom and
Christina I think we'll have a lot of
good bang yes no should I have this
message from the from the email but it's
kind of emotional yeah so uh should I
read it no I asked you so it's
uncomfortable so you can really I can
already say that I probably won't be
able to speak because I can do that but
I can't handle this show's over no I'll
sit here but I just probably I can't
really talk about the subjects cuz I get
too emotional okay
no you just give a shout-out to the yeah
hey we heard your message well he was
sweet I thought it was such a sweet
message and a very wholesome it's very
nice message so I wanted to read it yeah
comes from heart bridges hey Ethan ela
and podcast crew my name is Hart bridges
a month ago my mom was unexpectedly
diagnosed with stage 4 lymphoma she
recently passed her second treatment of
chemo she's doing pretty good but morale
is low she was such an active person
always working out and doing different
projects around the house but now she
feels weak and unable to accomplish
anything we started listening to the
podcast together about five months ago
we listened in the car sometimes around
the house and now at the hospital during
her six hour plus treatments we both
find y'all absolutely hilarious her
birthday is coming up in November on the
7th and I was wondering if I could get
y'all to sign a shirt for I'll pay for
the shirt and shipping if Ethan HeLa
could just sign it she would love it so
much and I know it'd make her smile just
pick a great shirt she wears a large
love yeah Bart bridges heart bridges
well obviously yeah dude do we have his
and I'll have to follow up dad maybe you
can follow up and get the address yeah
of course we are definitely sending a
care package out and I just that's so
sweet
I love this that they're watching
together and the mom I don't I love it I
think it's so I wish you the best and I
wish her mama healthy and speedy
recovery we know all too well
ela especially how tough that is so it's
very nice that you took the time to
write that and share you know it's not I
appreciate it I appreciate it man and I
wish you all the best you know
[ __ ] life it gets tough sometimes
unbearably tough you know and it's an
honor that we're able to provide some
kind of comfort for you guys I mean
that's that means a lot I mean it really
hearing that like this dude with his mom
getting chemo and watching our podcast
getting relief like all this [ __ ] we get
and everything it's like you got to cut
through it for these kind of stories
like no I appreciate taking the time
right then and of course were be honored
to hook your mom up we love love love
love and appreciate you so thank you for
writing us not to end on a heavy note
should we watch a psychic slam dunks a
bunch of people no no that's very long
one you know I guess there's you have to
assume that somebody likes this podcast
cuz people listen to it if you listen to
the comments in the and go to home page
on YouTube or read anywhere it feels
like nobody likes this podcast and
everybody wants it to go away but
somebody likes it I mean people watch it
right
this view out there this person likes it
so I guess we should keep you know it's
like okay alright well on that note we
did it how about guys it's Friday it is
Friday
my what the f oh this is our play out
song can you mute it in my room at least
cuz I can't even hear myself so
everybody can hear this damn whatever I
want to Renaud dandas dan is basically
I'm at that Emmys and Anna's play that
is run for the cube doing an acapella h3
theme song
hopefully it's low enough but every this
is a max Exodus everybody's leaving in
droves right chick my dudes have a
blessed beautiful Friday and I'm happy
weekend you know what life is a
challenge it's rough but if you listen
closely the music is playing
do you hear it I think we its soulful
and it's out there just view out there
you just got to listen it from you boy
do I hear clear
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]